[Music]
well brian as more groups become
eligible for the vaccine it is leading
to
longer lines fifteen thousand people
were vaccinated in just
one day over the weekend and that caused
some pretty long wait times at cashman
center
as kate houston reports local leaders
are working right now to expand
clinic hours in order to reach more
people after the morning rush lines at
the convention center moved fairly
quickly and right now they are
as well now the southern nevada health
district and the county are pulling
resources
to expand some clinic hours the
convention center is one of the closest
vaccination
sites to the strip many hospitality
workers like housekeeper flor paz
were here this morning to get their
first dose
you know around people a lot of people a
lot of people are coming out from other
states
you know so it's like it's very vital
for us when the site opened there was a
bit of a line some waited for over an
hour
boulder station line cook sean dowling
said he had a short weight
and it was worth it since he's now
serving up to 700 people a day
it's a lot of people were exposed to and
that we're exposing ourselves to
in order to accommodate hospitality
workers like dowling that work odd
shifts
county chairwoman marilyn kirkpatrick
says they're looking at expanding hours
at some clinics
to be open 12 to 14 hours each day we've
talked about the 24 hour process
and we think in time we can get to that
if we need it
but now we're looking at going to seven
or eight
in the evening starting very early in
the morning
kirkpatrick says this will apply to a
few different sites
at this point there's no plan for which
clinics will expand hours and when
kate houston 8 news now now we have
learned that some people got an email
from the health district just this
afternoon
telling them that their appointment
that's scheduled for this coming sunday
at cashman center will need to be
rescheduled it says there will not be a
vaccine event that day
we have reached out to the health
district for clarification on that and
have yet to hear back